twisted metals Dec I've been looking for
a reason to use this singing now I have
it so let's get started
twisted metal yeah I guess I don't need
that anymore I shouldn't keep it on for
the whole review but I'm not going to
come on alright so for those of you who
remember twisted metal was like got a
big back in the day for the PlayStation
hasn't been a twisted metal game for
over 10 years and now we have twisted
metal for the PlayStation 3 which I was
personally psyched for because I love me
some twisted metal back in the day the
story of twisted metal is actually kind
of cool there's a group of people
they're all maniacs and crazies they
compete in this battle mode death race
type thing the last one standing gets
one wish granted by calypso now
Calypso's like you know he's evil he
grants their wish but you know it's a
messed up version of it like oh I want
my father back alright here now he's a
zombie yeah he's kind of easy dick now
the single-player campaign in twisted
metal actually kind of disappointed me
but I can see why they did it the way
they did it there's ultimately three
story modes three stories for three
characters sweet tooth doll face and mr.
grim for those of you who know twisted
metal there's a lot more characters than
that that kind of disappointed me I like
going through single-player campaign
modes and seeing you know the story and
what their wish was and how they got
some messed up version of it that's
always cool to me now you have all the
vehicles to all the twisted metal
characters but you don't have those
characters the single-player campaign
isn't just you know like Oh beat these
five guys alright on to the next round
where you have to be five more guys on a
different level they're ultimately
challenge modes you know like I'll blow
up these two humongous semis while five
guys are in this battle mode they're all
coming after you also and the semis are
going to pump out new guys every couple
minutes so beat them fast oh hey that's
impossible you want to pull your teeth
out and throw your controller through
the window well you know I guess it's
supposed to be like that the fact that
you can pick any vehicle really kind of
negates the character that you're
playing as anyway so if you had to play
through the single-player campaign with
15 different people in which you would
pick the vehicle that works best for you
anyway that would get repetitive as hell
and get boring however the single-player
campaign is not where the gold of this
game lives
it's the multiplayer online oh yeah
twisted metal online is some fun
multiplayer [ __ ] twisted metal generally
speaking is if Mario Kart battle mode
had some really evil faireborn hell
spawn and came out for place day
three that is twisted metal and it's as
awesome as it sounds one of the things
I'd heard about this game is that it had
a really sketchy ass internet connection
for multiplayer like errors when people
try to join matches and when they're in
matches it'll drop them I've had
problems trying to join a match where
it's like alright try alright waiting
waiting waiting loading Oh error let's
try it again waiting waiting the air oh
my gosh really that was kind of annoying
but once you get into a match I haven't
had it dropped me from a match so once
you're in you should be good at least
that's my experience on it and when I
was going to play online I was like I'm
gonna get destroyed dude I've played
games online before these online people
they don't mess around
no it's different than playing like
Mortal Kombat online when you're going
against one guy you go against one guy
you're like I suck and I know I suck
because that guy really showed me how
much I suck and I need to you know go
into a corner and curl up and suck my
thumb and cry but when you have 15
people all playing against each other
online in a bunch of cars with rockets
and guns that go like 7,000 miles an
hour with nitroglycerine and armor and
machine guns it doesn't really matter
how good you are no-one's going to have
a lot of life for too long you're gonna
kill a lot of people you're gonna die a
lot yourself it's gonna be fun as hell
metal rockets explosions and death dude
that is what twisted metal is no one
lives through that [ __ ] and online modes
pretty much the online modes that you
would expect you know you have
deathmatch Team Deathmatch Last Man
Standing all these things are what they
sound like then they have capture the
flag mode which isn't called capture the
flag mode is called nuke mode but it's
totally capture the flag you go to their
base capture the leader and drag them
behind your car like Pablo Escobar and
[ __ ] and bring them back to your base
and then feed them to this big machine
that then shoots a rocket at their
statue it's capture the flag mode but
you know a little different totally
capture the flag but I'm telling you
this you play online and you're not even
gonna play the single-player campaign
anymore it is all about the online dude
I could do that for hours I do do that
for hours I'm perfectly happy that I
paid 60 bucks for twisted metal if
you're a twisted metal fan this you
gotta get this game you have to at first
when you play it you're so overloaded
you're like dude this is so fast there's
so many guns going off this is insanity
then you get into it you're like oh yes
chaos but I make the chaos I thrive on
the chaos you can actually get a sniper
rifle there's just one dude he was on
top of a building just sniping everyone
I got up there got behind him and just
slammed his Cardew but flying off the
pit I was like mm yeah it's a good
moment I
I was happy with that you know what I'm
still proud of that [ __ ] and the
soundtracks great - I mean you got death
metal you got hair metal you got Rob
Zombie you know what it's like
destroying other cars with machine guns
and rockets - dragula I do and it is as
great as it sounds so if you're worried
about this game you don't know if you
want to get it rent it
play it online I'm telling you you're
going to have fun once you get those
controls down and you won't put it down
which probably means you should probably
buy it after that so if you played the
twisted metal games have you played this
twisted metal game how do you like this
compared to the other ones comment below
let me know Mario Kart from Hell people
I'm telling you it's that fun and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more